figarolive 21h26 oui un peu en avance
Emmanuel Macron est allé plus vite que
prévu bonsoir vous venez de l'écouter le
président de la République sur France 2
vous voulez une analyse nous sommes là
vous ne l'avez pas écouté vous voulez un
débriefing nous sommes là aussi bonsoir
Renaud Girard
chroniqueur international au Figaro
merci d'être ici oh non on peut préciser
alors il devra parler à nouveau le 26
octobre donc dans deux semaines Emmanuel
Macron même format sur la même chaîne
France 2 avec 7 fois la politique
intérieure ce soir il devait parler
d'international c'est ce qu'il a fait
assez largement évidemment mais au vu de
la situation nationale il s'est exprimé
directement sur le quotidien des
Français je vous propose qu'on commence
par ça et puis après on passe à votre à
votre spécialité retour à la normale
dans la semaine qui vient concernant le
carburant il était très ferme très clair
est-ce qu'on peut le croire le président
on espère qu'on peut le croire parce que
c'est quand même tout à fait scandaleux
qu'un pays
soit prise en otage je pense par exemple
à ces infirmières qui font des soins à
domicile à domicile j'ai des gens très
malade ou chez des personnes âgées et
qui ne peuvent pas remplir
leur voiture d'essence
l'essence aujourd'hui c'est un produit
de première nécessité dans les sociétés
modernes dans les guerres c'est un
produit stratégique il est pas du tout
normal que une poignée
de salarié
d'ailleurs extrêmement bien payé parce
qu'il y a des gens qui travaillent
beaucoup par exemple des infirmières
dans des services d'urgence et ne
gagnent pas on peut le préciser on a eu
dans la semaine 4000 euros par mois
comme moi ont été dévoilés par total il
y a des vérifications c'est toujours
difficile d'établir les salaires mais de
fait les salaires sont plutôt bons pour
les raffineurs dans les différentes
raffineries comme dans d'autres
secteurs
les conducteurs de train les contrôleurs
du ciel etc qui sont extrêmement
privilégiés par rapport aux autres
travailleurs aux autres salariés du pays
parce qu'ils peuvent prendre
en
otage tout un pays c'est divine
évidemment inadmissible moi
personnellement je suis
contre la grève dans les services
publics c'est-à-dire que on peut pas
avoir le beurre et l'argent du beurre
dans les services publics vous êtes
avirable
dans dans les services publics vous êtes
un virage dans et donc vous avez vous
avez et vous devez faire du service au
public dans le privé dans le privé
votre société peut faire faillite vous
pouvez vous retrouver au chômage et si
vous devenez pas satisfaction vous
pouvez
virer alors là on peut comprendre que
dans une société privée par exemple je
ne sais pas qui fait je sais pas c'est
Hermès par exemple
et bien si on considère que le travail
bien rémunéré
que j'aimerais beaucoup en avoir mais
malheureusement je suis pas aussi
intelligent
pour avoir acheté des actions Hermès si
on considère que le travail est pas
assez bien rémunéré par rapport au
capital là il y a effectivement une
interaction un rapport de force entre le
travail le capital qui est tout à fait
normal en revanche là nous sommes dans
un quasi service public un cas Pasquier
a quasi monopole si demain moi je veux
ouvrir une raffinerie je pense que je ne
peux pas si vous voulez
il y a 8 en France on a je crois 6 de
Total et 2 de so ça fait pas un marché
si vous voulez ça fait pas un marché de
concurrence et donc vous avez des gens
qui simplement prennent en otage le pays
c'est inadmissible il faut un retour
à l'ordre en France et on ne peut pas
admettre
on ne peut pas admettre que une poignée
d'ouvriers CGT extrêmement bien payé
paralyse tout un pays Emmanuel Macron
qui a donc justifié aujourd'hui les
réquisitions dans certaines des
entreprises il a dit que si cela
continue notamment chez Total alors que
les négociations sont engagées ils
pourraient y en avoir d'autres de ces
réquisitions il est sur un fil quand
même le président de la République
est-ce qu'il a peur d'une forme de
colère sociale parce qu'on peut le
préciser Renaud il y a une marche
dimanche sous l'impulsion de la gauche
de la Nupe il y a l'utilisation plus que
probable du 49,3 la semaine prochaine
qui risque d'agiter encore les tensions
est-ce qu'en ce moment c'est très
compliqué alors la nups ferait mieux de
protéger les salariés qui sont précaires
ce qui n'est pas le cas des raffineries
qui ne gagne pas 4000 euros par mois
et ce qui est aussi assez intolérable
dans le combat de la nuque c'est qu'elle
veut faire un troisième tour social bah
ces élections législatives elle avait
qu'à les gagner ces élections Monsieur
Mélenchon disait qu'il allait devenir
Premier ministre mais il avait qu'à
gagner sa majorité au Parlement il
serait devenu mécanique mécaniquement
Premier ministre on aurait vu d'ailleurs
la politique qu'il aurait menée on
aurait vu si la politique qu'il aurait
mener était plus efficace notamment
parce qu'on peut être jugé je vais la
France peut être jugé par rapport à ses
voisins notamment voilà mais le peuple
français n'a pas élu n'a pas donné une
majorité à Monsieur Mélenchon pour qu'il
soit Premier ministre et il parle donc
il voulait pas
la troisième tour social c'est
inadmissible voilà c'est à cette
anti-démocratique je veux bien vous
parler d'Emmanuel Macron je rappelle
simplement que Emmanuel Macron il a
gagné l'élection présidentielle contre
Monsieur Mélenchon Monsieur Mélenchon
aurait pu gagner mais lui il a gagné
voilà dernière question sur cette
question de politique intérieure puisque
l'interview de ce soir que vous venez de
suivre portez très largement sur la
politique internationale il met un peu
les Français de ado Emmanuel Macron il a
plusieurs fois critiqué les syndicats
qui refusaient de dialogue social c'est
un peu agité à ce moment là le président
de la République qui a critiqué aussi
des échéances syndicales on sait qu'il y
a des échéances syndicales à la CGT
notamment en 2023 des échéances
politiques en gros regardez ces méchants
grévistes pour se mettre l'opinion
publique dans la poche non
écoutez j'ai pas été très impressionné
j'ai pas trouvé que le président était
d'air très clair sur ce sujet je trouve
qu'il a été bien plus clair sur les
sujets internationaux j'ai pas trouvé ça
très clair parce que en fait il faudrait
qu'il nous explique pourquoi il y a que
8 raffineries pourquoi il y a que deux
sociétés qui font la raffinerie
jusqu'à preuve du contraire nous vivons
en économie de marché c'est-à-dire ce
que dit les textes qui nous régissent
puisque nous sommes régis par le traité
de Lisbonne par l'Union européenne qui
dit que notre économie est une économie
de marché une économe une marché ça veut
dire quoi ça veut dire une économie avec
des une concurrence sans monopole parce
que sinon avec des monopoles le
capitalisme ne marche pas
et bien
visiblement dans les raffineries de
pétrole nous n'avons pas un véritable
marcher nous avons pas véritable
concurrence visiblement il y a une
collusion
à cartel si vous voulez entre les
ouvriers
les syndicalistes CGTistes de Esso et
ceux de Total et donc qui prennent en
otage la France je trouve que là la
réponse du président j'espère que les
choses seront rétablies mais je trouve
aussi qu'on a trop tardé et que c'est
une faute du gouvernement
d'être arrivé à cette situation où les
Français doivent faire la queue la
dernière fois que j'ai connu ça moi
c'était pour nos parents et
grands-parents ont connu ça sur la crise
de Suez que j'ai connu ça en 1968 mais
sinon on n'a jamais connu des des queues
comme ça c'est une petite
affaire de similaire en 2010 Nicolas
Sarkozy avait procédé là à des Ré
également Renault est-ce que on passe à
l'Ukraine quand même c'est très
important spécialiste des questions
internationales il est 21h35 nous
débriefons ensemble c'était interview du
président Macron sur France 2 je suis
avec chrono girardaire chroniqueur
international au Figaro on peut on peut
se demander ce que nous a apporté plus
frais dans la République quoi de neuf
sous le soleil toujours un peu le même
discours avec cette entre deux on livre
des armes mais nous ne sommes surtout
pas en guerre il s'y tient coûte que
coûte à cette doctrine bah c'est quand
même un peu la vérité si vous voulez
il s'est quand même je dirais d'une
guerre de Sécession c'est l'Ukraine qui
veut sortir du monde russe dans lequel
il a été pendant
trois siècles et demi alors c'est tout à
fait compréhensible d'ailleurs c'était
ça c'est fait pacifiquement en 1991
c'est un président russe élu qui
s'appelle Boris ciel signe qui était le
plein de Poutine en politique qui a
accepté la séparation entre la Russie et
l'Ukraine et la Biélorussie qui mène
dans un dîner du 8 décembre 1991 à 10 au
président
ukrainien que j'ai connu d'ailleurs qui
s'appelait kraftwick qu'il pouvait
garder la Crimée tout ça a été validé
par des référendums populaires
ces présidents qui ont fait ce partage
divorce si vous voulez de l'Empire russe
était élu au suffrage universel
c'est un nouvel ordre du monde et de la
de l'Empire russe qui s'est mis en place
la Russie elle-même en 1994 à donner
son accord garantit territoriale de
l'Ukraine en échange de l'abandon par
celle-ci de ces armes nucléaires et
effectivement en envahissant
cette on avait sans l'Ukraine
Vladimir Poutine à tout remis en cause
mais c'est quand même ça reste quand
même une affaire intérieure entre
anciens cousin si vous voulez je
comprends ce que nous sommes pas bah oui
si vous voulez
Kiev quand moi j'étais à l'école on
apprenait au lycée qui avait trois
grandes villes russes on les appelait
russes il y avait Kiev enfin c'était la
petite Russie la Russie Blanche la
Biélorussie et puis la Grande Russie à
Moscou on disait c'était Moscou
Leningrad ça s'appelait
à l'époque mais il y a eu des traités il
y a eu des textile des traités pacta
sous une servante comme on dit en latin
il faut respecter les traités consignes
que des traités tout à fait librement
par là Russie ce sont pas les
Occidentaux qu'on obligé les Russes de
divorcer des Ukrainiens ça c'est fait à
l'amiable entre les Ukrainiens les
Russes et effectivement Poutine a voulu
revenir dessus mais c'est vrai que ça
nous concerne pas au premier chef
puisque nous nous sommes dans une
alliance qui s'appelle alliance
Atlantique est-ce que finalement on ne
prend pas Vladimir Poutine pardon pour
un imbécile en disant non non nous on
n'est pas en guerre contre vous alors
qu'il sait très bien le président russe
que la France livre des armes à
l'Ukraine c'est ça la diplomatie c'est
tout c'est vrai c'est vrai qu'on est
d'une certaine manière en trop
belligérance avec des Ukrainiens puisque
nous leur livrons effectivement du
matériel nous formons leur soldats etc
mais c'est vrai ainsi que face à une
agression aussi flagrante qui était
d'ailleurs pas du tout nécessaire
puisque l'Ukraine ne menaçait pas du
tout aussi
la Russie comme l'a dit le président
Macron est un territoire immense donc
les Russes avaient tout intérêt
peut-être à développer leur propre
territoire avant d'essayer de prendre
celui des autres bon
face à cette agression
de gens qui vivaient très tranquillement
chez eux
on peut comprendre effectivement
qu'on les aide alors livrant des sables
d'autant plus qu'ils ont montré beaucoup
de bravoue et beaucoup de détermination
à défendre leur pays maintenant
maintenant
cette affaire à trop durer et il faut en
sortir il faut à tout prix et là le
président Macron a raison parce qu'il
fait davantage d'efforts diplomatiques
que c'est collègues européens
et il a tout à fait raison de parler il
a tout à fait raison de parler de
négociation on ne peut pas
se permettre qu'un conflit au départ
régional devienne un conflit mondial on
a déjà eu ça en 1914 on va pas répéter
la même sotise ou même crime contre
l'humanité et donc il faut effectivement
trouver une solution revenir
aux droits internationales avoir sans
doute que les
Ukrainiens recouvrent leurs droits sans
doute davantage par la négociation et
que les Russes soient rassurés quand
leur sécurité qu'il y est sans doute une
discussion une discussion dire générale
sur toute la sécurité en Europe qui avec
les Russes et donc le président Macron a
tout à fait raison de parler de
négociation mais on comprend aussi que
on ne pouvait pas laisser tomber des
gens qui sont agressés de manière
les scènes absolument terribles à bout
de chat et ailleurs et on a une
discussion à nouveau très long de deux
heures et je les convaincu
d'accepter cette mission du directeur
général convaincu aussi le président
zellinski puisqu'il est passé par le sol
ukrainien et donc il y a eu une mission
de l'Agence internationale de l'énergie
atomique qui s'est rendu à sauridja vous
le voyez cette centrale qui est dans le
la région du Dombas et il a revendiqué
non mais la maîtrise
mais il y a une chose qui est encore
plus grave c'est qu'il mette en danger
la sûreté de cette centrale
voilà ce que dit Emmanuel Macron alors
là on précise il parlait de l'agence qui
assure la sécurité nucléaire qui est une
organisation un organisme de l'ONU mais
en tout cas il le montre il dit je veux
qu'on parle avec Vladimir Poutine
pourquoi les auditeurs comprennent bien
oui il y a une il y a une effectivement
une usine nucléaire ça pourrait déjà et
il y a une agence internationale de
l'énergie nucléaire exactement qui
étudie qui contrôle le fait que tous les
pays qui ont qui ont signé ce qu'on
appelle le TNP le traité de non
prolifération hier ne font pas n'utilise
pas des recherches pour la pour le
nucléaire civil qui est normalement
accessible à tous les pays pour en faire
du nucléaire militaire voilà c'est de la
principale de la Ia et par ailleurs ils
ont évidemment une expertise donc on a
voulu que dans ce conflit faire visiter
n'est-ce pas là et effectivement le
président c'est beaucoup
c'est beaucoup enfin beaucoup travaillé
pour qu'on puisse aboutir cette solution
il existe c'est pas la seule chose il a
réussi à faire en Ukraine c'est lui qui
a eu l'idée de saisir le nul au Conseil
de sécurité de l'ONU à partir de la fin
mais
2022 pour créer ce fameux corridor de
céréales entre
Odessa et le Bosphore et alors ensuite
évidemment c'était repris par les Turcs
et c'est tout à fait normal puisque le
Bosphore c'est turc et puis par le
secrétaire général de des Nations Unies
mais au départ cette idée était une idée
française portée par le président
Emmanuel Macron qui m'a fait pas au
Conseil de sécurité et c'est une bonne
idée ça fait progresser un peu les
choses là où je voulais en venir c'est
qu'il est surtout je l'ai encore eu la
semaine dernière Vladimir Poutine il lui
parle il continue à lui parler est-ce
qu'il n'est pas trop tendre avec
Vladimir Poutine bah c'est ce qui lui
est reproché à tort parce qu'on fait
jamais assez d'efforts pour la paix et
par exemple
Emmanuel Macron a essayé a fait beaucoup
d'efforts pour que les Américains et les
Iraniens puissent parler directement
pour qu'on puisse revenir à l'accord
nucléaire les Iraniens renonçaient à la
bombe atomique l'accord nucléaire qui
avait été dénoncée par les Américains
Emmanuel Macron a fait beaucoup
d'efforts pour cela vous souvenez le
sommet de Biarritz etc Cela n'a pas
abouti c'est-à-dire pas la faute
d'Emmanuel Macron c'est la faute du
Guide
suprême iranien et bien oui il a
Emmanuel Macron a travaillé beaucoup
pour rien mais c'était pour la paix et
bien moi je salue ce travail d'Emmanuel
Macron même s'il est pas
aujourd'hui un succès comme je salue
d'ailleurs ce qu'il a essayé de faire
pour le Liban
je trouve qu'on ne travaille jamais
assez pour la paix et heureusement je
dirais heureusement qu'on a aujourd'hui
un grand leader européen qui a su garder
à une voix de dialogue ouverte avec
Vladimir Poutine parce que l'urgence
pour tout notre continent et même je
dirais toute notre planète c'est de
faire baisser les tensions et cette
histoire de zapporijah de confier ça à
la ua ça fait baisser l'extension comme
d'ailleurs les couloirs céréaliers qui
permettent à l'Ukraine
d'exporter
ces céréales qui permettent aussi
d'ailleurs à la Russie de ne pas être
sanctionné quand elle exporte ses
engrais et ses céréales
21h45 nous sommes en direct nous
débrisons avec chrono Girard grand
reporter chroniqueur international au
Figaro c'est interview d'Emmanuel Macron
ça a duré une c'était sur France
télévision sur France 2 une question et
je montre Renault votre votre chronique
mardi tous les mardis évidemment à forte
rapport de force établi négociation
possible Emmanuel Macron la répéter
plusieurs fois négociation négociation
il faudra s'assoir à la table mais
aujourd'hui est-ce que les Ukrainiens
veulent s'asseoir à la table des
négociations alors il a dit on les
laisse choisir ce sont eux qui
choisiront quand ils voudront s'asseoir
à la table de négociation mais il faudra
que ça arrive est-ce qu'aujourd'hui
c'est possible
alors les
Ukrainiens
pensent ou certains pensent que c'est la
fin de la mer russe moi je pense qu'il
faut être prudent la mérus a subi des
revers mais elle va quand même se
réorganiser dans son Histoire des c'est
pas la première fois que l'armée russe
subit des revers avant de réussir à se
réorganiser et la subit des revers
est-ce qu'elle n'existe plus je crois
qu'il faut être prudent alors les
Ukrainiens
veulent reprendre
donc les quatre blastes jusqu'au basse
qui a été qui ont été
annexés c'est uniquement par la Russie
on rappelle que
la communauté internationale ne
reconnaît certainement pas ces années
bien sûr
puisqu'il y a eu un sorte de partage
avec
91 à l'amiable et ensuite
à partir de 2014
il y a eu des prorus qui se sont
rebellés l'âme
ukrainienne l'été 2014 a envoyé
à essayer de les mater et les prorus
avec les deux l'armée russe évidemment
les abattus à deux reprises voilà en
Crimée et dans certaines parties de
l'est de l'Ukraine voilà et alors la
Crimée c'est un peu spécial parce que la
Crimée a toujours été pro russe et donc
si les Ukrainiens veulent veulent
reprendre la Crimée et le référendum
même s'il n'était pas légal sur le plan
international mais on a fait exactement
la même chose nous occidentaux avec le
Kosovo par parenthèse en fait on a fait
exactement la même chose que ce que nous
reprochons aujourd'hui au Russe c'est à
dire que le temps a fait une guerre en
faveur d'une province sécessionniste qui
s'appelle le Kosovo contre la Serbie on
a fait une guerre c'était printemps
1999 on a bon bardé les principales
villes serment faire céder la Serbie
comme les Russes aujourd'hui font la
guerre pour aider les sécessionnistes
russophone du Dombasle
ils sont pas clairement poussés par
Moscou c'est eux qui veulent à la base
et Moscou qui les aident c'est pas
Moscou plutôt qu'il les pousse à à se
rebeller si vous voulez il y avait au
sein de de l'électorat ukrainien il y
avait quand même un président prorus
pianovitch et ce président avait quand
même été élu démocratiquement en 2010
sous le contrôle des observateurs de
l'Union européenne donc il y a eu une
époque
quand même
un pourcentage important de la
population qui était tout à fait
pro-rousse il y a une révolution
à qui elle a la capitale qui a renversé
les Russes disent que c'est un coup
d'État mais enfin les révolutions c'est
toujours des coups d'État qui a renversé
le président élu démocratiquement qui
était Yannick évidemment aujourd'hui les
prorus sont beaucoup moins nombreux
parce que même les russophone et ceux
qui étaient autrefois prorus ne peuvent
pas accepter de voir des chars à venir
et raser leur vie à Mario Paul Philippe
que je connais bien les gens parlent ne
parlaient que le Russe ils étaient tout
à fait amis de la Russie
des contradictions pour certains qui
sentaient très ukrainiens et qui
parlaient russes c'était parfois
difficile
les gens parlent c'est pas du tout c'est
pas du tout la question mais là
effectivement
ces gens du des quatre blasques qui ont
été annexés ils se sont habitués à être
ukrainien c'est c'est des choix
d'ailleurs ce qu'il faut dire c'est que
les référendum même dans ces oblates le
référendum d'indépendance c'est des
majorités de plus de 80% qui ont adopté
l'indépendance de l'Ukraine seul la
Crimée était très tangente à 50%. alors
le problème de la Crimée c'est si les
moi je pense que la solution pour la
Crimée si il faut attendre 15 ans et on
reprendra le sujet dans 15 ans parce que
si aujourd'hui les
Ukrainiens veulent reprendre par la
force la clé mais d'abord ils trouveront
face à eux une population très hostile
parce que les Crimée c'est comme ça sont
toujours été courus et par ailleurs vous
avez l'Union nationale en Russie
sur la Crimée même l'opposant qui est en
prison Navalny par exemple il a toujours
dit que la Crimée était russe donc je
pense que pour que le conflit ne dure
pas éternellement il faut reprendre les
négociations qui ont lieu déjà
d'ailleurs eu entre les Russes et les
Ukrainiens au mois de mars à Istanbul ou
on aurait une sorte de neutralité
internationale parce que les Russes
considèrent ce serait une provocation
que l'Ukraine rentre dans l'OTAN les
Russes ne veulent pas avoir des missiles
nucléaires
disposés en Ukraine et pointée sur
Moscou voilà
et ensuite peut-être alors peut-être des
référendums mais contrôler par la
communauté pour voir exactement ce que
veulent les populations des différents
blases moi je pense que les populations
par exemple de zapporija ou de Kerson
elles sont proscriennes peut-être ils
seront pro russe pourquoi parce qu'ils
ont été bombardés pendant
8 ans voilà de 2020 mais je pense que il
y a un moment où il faut arrêter les
jusqu'au boutistics et il a eu tout à
fait raison il faut arrêter les
jusqu'au-boutistes et mais bien sûr que
c'est pas à nous d'obliger un peuple qui
se bat très voyellement d'aller à la
table à la table de négociation mais on
peut quand même les encourager et on
peut aussi
faire en sorte
que le dialogue reprenne est ce qu'on
appelle en anglais des honest brokers
des interminières sincères il ne faut il
faut à tout prix et je pense que le
président Macron a raison il faut pas
que ce conflit au départ régional qui
est une sorte de Sécession si vous
voulez de l'Ukraine par rapport au monde
russe et qui veulent reprendre leur
libre qui veulent prendre leur liberté
par rapport à ce monde russe il faut pas
que cette guerre de Sécession devienne
une guerre européenne et une guerre
mondiale Renault on essaye de faire un
peu plus rapide parce qu'on a encore
plusieurs sujets à traiter je rappelle
quand même que nous sommes en train de
débriefer
l'événement l'événement c'est le nom de
l'émission à laquelle a participé
Emmanuel Macron vous avez toutes les
réactions tout ce qui s'est dit tous les
extraits sur Le Figaro.fr Steve Tendret
John teamsit Mensa d'une main de maître
vous trouvez ça sur Le Figaro.fr les
sanctions alors il assume la cohérence
Emmanuel Macron il veut à tout prix dire
moi je défends une certaine idée de la
liberté quitte à affaiblir l'économie
française mais il a du mal à convaincre
avec ses sanctions quand même il nous
dit nous peut-être pas assez clair
personnellement moi je pense que c'est
normal de mettre des sanctions comme il
a dit sur le système sur les gens qui
sont favorables à cette guerre parce que
cette guerre est injuste et est une
violation du droit international où tout
le l'entourage de Poutine je comprends
très bien je comprends très bien qu'on
fasse des sanctions contre le système
militaire de faire en sorte que empêcher
de pas aider en tout cas l'industrie
russe à refaire des armes donc c'est
tout les sanctions sur des pièces
détachées etc mais je suis contre les
punitions collectives je suis contre les
punitions collectives contre le peuple
russe je suis contre les interdictions
de visa sur les Russes au contraire les
étudiants russes il faut les inviter en
Europe pour montrer comment fonctionne
notre démocratie je suis contre
l'isolement de la Russie et aujourd'hui
les sanctions générales et je pense que
ça fonctionne d'abord je suis pas sûr
qu'elle fonctionne et je trouve que
c'est fou la Ursula vanderlain on a
l'impression que la seule chose qu'elle
fasse c'est toujours des présidents
et quand on étudie finalement bien les
choses on s'aperçoit que les sanctions
que prend Ursula vanderlayen que
sanctionne les sanctions et ben moi je
vais vous répondre que sanctionne les
sanctions les sanctions sanctionnent
avant tout l'Europe et profite
évidemment aux États-Unis et sans doute
aussi d'ailleurs à la Chine mais les
premiers bénéficiaires ce sont les
États-Unis qui comme vous l'avez dit
vendent l'orgas de 6 5 fois plus cher et
ce café Ursula vanderlayen
c'est que c'est elle qu'elle commençait
à sanctionner il y a des mesures
européennes pour interdire l'importation
de pétrole russe sauf pour la Hongrie et
la Tchéquie interdire en tout cas de
d'apporter du pétrole russe par bateau
et ensuite c'est vrai que ce sont les
Russes qui ont commencé à couper le
robinet du gaz
c'est la Commission européenne
Macron et c'est ça qui est parfois
difficilement entendable pour les
Français j'imagine il nous dit oui
depuis que les Russes ont coupé les
robinets le prix augmente le prix de
l'électricité le prix augmente
alors je pense qu'on s'est laissé trop
tirer par des gens qui sont vraiment
anti-rhus par nature pour des raisons
historiques d'ailleurs très
compréhensible et polonais des baltes
etc
et que
c'est une mauvaise politique qui est
celle de faire une petite qui ne soit
pas celle de ses intérêts et les
intérêts de
l'industrie européenne c'est de ne pas
prendre de retard par rapport à
l'industrie chinoise et l'industrie
américaine et par ailleurs l'histoire a
montré que les punitions collectives
étaient toujours contre-productive donc
moi je ne vois aucune raison pour punir
par exemple les banques de dépôt russe
les banques qui prennent le dépôt des
petits épargne russe pourquoi les punir
pourquoi les empêcher d'envoyer des
mandats à leur famille ailleurs en
Europe etc pourquoi pourquoi non pas de
punition collective oui des sanctions
sur l'appareil
militaro politique
qui a agressé
qui agresse toujours l'Ukraine oui ce
sont des sanctions c'est la totalement
justifiée on avance il y a une question
sur l'écologie alors là il le répète et
c'est peut-être le grand dilemme
macroniste bataille de l'indépendance
énergétique contre la bataille
écologique
il ne s'est pas choisi là nous sommes en
train en ce moment en France de rouvrir
des centrales à charbon c'est largement
le cas en Allemagne c'est un peu le cas
partout en Europe il ne tranche pas la
Emmanuel Macron et nous convainc pas en
tout cas je fais un choix dans un sens
je fais un choix dans l'autre on voit
que chez les écolos en tout cas et c'est
toute la gauche européenne la haine des
Russes l'a emporté sur le désir de
verdir la planète et de verdir
nos vies et là il a été très diplomate
mais est-ce qu'il peut faire autrement
mais ce que n'a pas dit Macron c'est que
il n'a pas parlé de l'erreur stratégique
qu'a fait notre partenaire allemand
d'abandonner l'électricité nucléaire
nucléaire qui ne pollue pas qui ne fait
pas de CO2 pour des raisons de politique
politicienne pour plaire aux parties
vertes de l'époque c'était après
Fukushima mais simplement il faut
rappeler qu'il y a des failles au Japon
et des tremblements de terre il y en a
pas en Allemagne vous me permettez de
vous apporter la contradiction d'accord
les Allemands oui ils ont beaucoup plus
de centrales à charbon que nous parce
qu'ils ont abandonné le nucléaire vous
avez raison nous notre nucléaire il est
pas en très grande forme et c'est à
cause de ça que nous ouvrons des
centrales à charbon il y a des
responsabilités à voir il faudrait qu'il
y ait par exemple peut-être une
commission d'enquête parlementaire on
avait une fantastique
un outil nucléaire absolument
fantastique créée par le général de
Gaulle et Georges Pompidou et Valéry
Giscard d'Estaing comment on a pu
laisser dépérir cet instrument
fantastique qui était le nucléaire
français comme on a été incapable de
l'entretenir comment était incapable
de former des générations de techniciens
là effectivement il faudrait y avoir
c'est un grand échec français c'est une
honte industrielle française
Colbert doit se retourner dans sa tombe
en voyant ça il faudrait avoir une
enquête je pense que pour être si vous
voulez que je sois un peu critique et là
je vais l'être allez garder manuels
de tout le monde allez-y mais voilà
c'est que je pense que Hollande a pris
une décision absolument aberrante
politicienne qui était de fermer
Fessenheim il faut savoir que l'usine de
Fessenheim fonctionnait fonctionner
comme une horloge et avait été c'était
la plus vieille de France oui mais peu
importe elle fonctionnait comme une
horloge elle avait subi tous les tests
positivement elle fonctionnait comme une
horloge pour des raisons politiciennes
pour avoir un accord avec les Verts
Hollande promet la
fermeture de fesses mais ce qu'on peut
reprocher à
Macron c'est que parce qu'il avait pris
cette espèce de bouffon de Hulot dans
son gouvernement attention à ce que vous
voulez
voilà voilà qu'il avait pas du tout sa
place pour devenir voilà alors là c'est
une vidéo politique je pense que
Monsieur Hulot était sans doute un très
bon animateur de télévision enfin je ne
sais pas je regardais pas vraiment ces
émissions je dois vous l'avouer mais
sans doute sympathique peut-être
d'ailleurs un peu trop engageant
visiblement avec on va passer
pour lui ce soir voilà on continue non
non en tout cas il a été ministre c'est
sans doute un mauvais choix de mes
numéros et de toute façon il a trahi
ensuite Macron et moi je m'en moque de
ça mais ce qui est gras c'est une erreur
d'État c'est qu'on est fermé Fessenheim
c'est quelque chose
de dingue d'avoir un outil qui marche
parfaitement et le fermer pour plaire un
ministre écologique ou pour aller dans
le sens des Allemands qui ont fait une
faute stratégique que Emmanuel Macron
n'a pas osé relever ce soir dans son
débat pour des raisons qu'on peut
comprendre parce que moi je suis
journaliste donc je peux dire exactement
tout ce qui tout ce qui tout ce qui
passe par ma tête
un peu différent il est obligé d'être
plus diplomate et ça se comprend et
justement allez j'ai trois questions
encore on va les aborder ensemble on
finisse ce débrief de l'interview se
debriefing de l'interview d'Emmanuel
Macron oui il est peut-être diplomate
parce qu'il répète toujours ce mot
Europe Europe Europe on peut lui
accorder la constance sur cette question
il change de pied régulièrement
notamment sur le nucléaire venait d'en
parler avec le début de son premier
quinquennat à la fin de son premier
quinquennat sur l'Europe alors là
Emmanuel Macron la ligne est claire lui
il pense que c'est l'Europe qui nous
sortira de la panade alors il faut
reconnaître que sur le covid la réponse
européenne a été bonne il a été très
critiqué mais la réalité c'est qu'en
fait l'Europe et l'effort uni de l'Union
européenne a fait que dans la lutte
contre le covid on a même des eu des
résultats meilleurs que les Américains
alors que c'est les Américains qui
avaient réussi à attirer tous les
meilleurs chercheurs chez eux y compris
les chercheurs français qui ont mis au
point le moderna
mais la réponse européenne a été il faut
le reconnaître très efficace il y a deux
une deuxième quand même efficacité ou
succès de l'Europe c'est l'euro on avait
est-ce qu'il a raison de s'y tenir
est-ce qu'il avait raison peut-être
avant tout le monde face à Madrid Le Pen
face à Jean-Luc Mélenchon qui ne sont
pas des pro-européens et qu'il a dû
avancer sur la scène politique française
à l'énergie il est évident comme ça a
été le cas pour le covid que la
mutualisation
des moyens comme d'ailleurs aussi en
matière financière il a obtenu la
mutualisation de certaines dettes pour
les investissements européens importants
ça c'est il a réussi à convaincre
l'Allemagne de faire ça et bien oui je
pense que la mutualisation en Europe des
situations énergétiques ne peut que
renforcer parce que si vous voulez faut
voir les compétiteurs de l'Union
européenne vous avez les Américains avec
un seul marché de l'énergie pour les
Américains vous avez les Chinois un seul
marché d'énergie et bien d'en faire un
seul marché d'énergie avec des
solidarités pour l'espace européen
je trouve que ça a du sens oui je le dis
là le papier regardez cet article John
team City vous résume tout ce qu'il
s'est dit dans cette interview
d'Emmanuel Macron guerre en Ukraine
carburant Arménie voilà un nouveau sujet
que je voulais aborder avec vous Renault
Girard on peut rappeler ce qui se passe
là-bas brièvement quand même parce que
je suis pas sûr c'est une guerre un
conflit qui passe sous les radars en ce
moment vu de la situation en Ukraine
rappelez-nous rapidement ce qu'il se
passe en Arménie en Arménie ce qui s'est
passé c'est un peu compliqué
vous essayez de me faire simple alors
vous avez le peuple
arménien
et puis l'Arménie et puis le peuple
d'Azerbaïdjan c'était deux République de
l'Union soviétique le peuple arménien
ayant été par ailleurs victimes d'un
génocide commis par les Turcs en 1915
d'accord c'était ils étaient dans
l'empire turc
et les survivants se sont retrouvés dans
cette république d'Arménie qui est
petite vous l'avez vu et il y avait
d'autres républiques dont celle de
l'Azerbaïdjan dans l'URSS
par ailleurs dans ces
découpage qui ont été faits par Staline
et les autres commissaire en nationalité
et bien on avait mis une région
majoritairement peuplée d'Arméniens à
l'intérieur du territoire de
l'Azerbaïdjan c'est ce qu'il a dit
Emmanuel Macron c'est s'appelle au
Karaba c'est à dire qu'en droit
internationale c'est vrai le haut garaba
ça fait partie du territoire de
l'Azerbaïdjan et la France normalement
reconnaît mais ces peuplés d'Arméniens
qui ne veulent pas obéir au gouvernement
de Bakou président
donc ensuite qu'est-ce qui s'est passé
et bien il y a une guerre les
Arméniens ont gagné dans les années 91
92 et on prie même des territoires aux
azerbaïdjanais
parce que vous avez des azéries aussi
c'est une des titres vous avez des
azéries en Iran d'accord il faut dire
les Azerbaïdjanais d'accord qui sont
pour la plupart à zerry mais pour vous
avez raison vous pouvez avoir des
Juifs azerbaïdjanais par exemple il y en
a des
voilà donc et donc là il y a eu
effectivement une
offensive de l'Azerbaïdjan contre les
Arméniens du Caraba d'accord où ils ont
repris une grande partie du haut carbal
la moitié pas tout là il a fait une
petite bon et c'était il y a pas pu être
très précis le président là je montre
sur une carte du monde d'Europe en tout
cas où se trouve cette zone la France
est ici et nous allons voilà tout est
lui vous avez vous avez alors Emmanuel
Macron très vite s'est engagé à fond
dans essayer d'organiser notamment il a
fait ça à Bruxelles etc ils invitaient à
dîner essayer de faire créer un dialogue
entre le Premier ministre élu d'Amélie
patinion et le président Alif
d'Azerbaïdjan il est fait un vrai effort
c'est cette Sévrier c'est une marque
je dirais de la présidence Macron c'est
qui veut être honnesse broker il veut
elle ta faiseur de paix dans le monde et
il a raison il fait beaucoup d'efforts
pour ça et là ce qui s'est passé
récemment c'est comme les frontières
entre l'Azerbaïdjan et
et l'armée n'ont pas été bien tracée on
envoie une commission pour retracer ces
frontières et pour observer les
violations de frontières cette fois
entre l'Arménie elle-même et
l'Azerbaïdjan que s'est-il passé dans
les dernières semaines la précisément
est-ce que les azerbadjanais ont envahi
l'Arménie c'est ça alors ils ont pas ils
ont pas envahi toute l'Arménie mais ils
sont pénétrés dans le territoire
Arméniens les Arméniens se sont
défendues il y a eu des dizaines et des
dizaines de morts et c'est pour ça que
vous avez eu l'appel de Sylvain Tesson
qui est bien toutes ces régions
d'ailleurs russes
c'est sûr que le peuple arménien est un
peuple enclavé et qui est effectivement
beaucoup moins nombreux d'ailleurs que
le club le peuple d'Azerbaïdjan est
beaucoup moins riche parce que
laserbaïdjan a le pétrole de Bakou Bakou
c'était l'ancienne capitale pétrolière
de pourquoi
enclavé on peut dire pourquoi c'est un
pays en clavier parce qu'il a des
tentations occidentales on peut le dire
plus tôt mais il a aussi la Turquie au
nord la Géorgie et la Russie et à l'Est
l'Azerbaïdjan et il y a quasiment aucun
lien avec l'Europe voilà alors en fait
géographique toutes ces populations
qui ont quand même vécu des siècles et
des siècles ensemble mais il y a eu des
drames on a parlé du génocide etc la
Turquie évidemment soutient
l'Azerbaïdjan les drapeaux sont
quasiment à dire comparables entre les
deux pays mais
c'est évidemment que l'intérêt serait
que les Arméniens travaillent en bonne
intelligence avec les Azerbaïdjanais ça
serait tout et d'ailleurs ce serait le
moyen de développer considérablement
l'Arménie
le problème c'est que les Azerbaïdjanais
je vous demande de me faire court pour
qu'on comprenne
les conflits posts soviétiques sont très
compliqués et c'est comme d'ailleurs
l'histoire de l'Ukraine c'est très
compliqué on peut pas résumer et bien
par exemple les Azerbaïdjanais disent
sur le ok nous voulons l'application du
droit international et les habitants du
okaba dit nous voulons le droit à
l'autodétermination des peuples nous
voulons pas bon voilà donc c'est très
difficile
mais il faut faire déjà cesser des
incidents de frontières et les attaques
de l'armée azerbaïdienne ce qui est
devenu meilleur grâce au drone fourni
par les Turcs meilleur que l'armée
arménienne c'était l'inverse il y a 30
ans mais maintenant elle est devenue
meilleur et donc aujourd'hui le pays le
plus faible
c'est l'Arménie dans ce conflit et c'est
pour ça que que Sylvain Tesson et que
Macron alors
question peut-on vraiment les aider
justement parce que nous sommes on l'a
dit au début de ce débriefing de
l'intervie d'Emmanuel Macron nous sommes
l'Europe en tout cas dépendante du gaz
russe depuis plusieurs années il n'y a
plus de gaz russe et certains pays
européens ont signé avec l'Azerbaïdjan
qui a également du gaz est-ce
qu'aujourd'hui on peut et bien à nouveau
entrer en conflit avec l'Azerbaïdjan
pour défendre l'Arménie alors même que
maintenant c'est laserbaï gens qui
fournit une partie du gaz européen
c'était une qui a été
effectivement
donné assez répandue qui dit
on
sanctionne voilà on n'accepte pas
le l'énergie qui vient de Russie
laquelle agressé l'Ukraine mais on
accepte très volontiers
l'énergie de l'Azerbaïdjan qui agresse
l'Arménie donc les gens disent c'est de
poids de mesures
c'est sans doute je n'ai pas encore lu
le texte de Sylvain Tesson parce que
d'ailleurs pas paru
mais j'imagine que c'est un argument
qu'il développera
avoir froid avec les Arméniens plutôt
que chaud avec le gaz azerbajanais voilà
ce qu'il est ce que dit si Emmanuel
Macron a réitéré son soutien nous
n'abandonnerons pas les Arméniens les
arméniennes et les Arméniens mais là là
par exemple
ce qui n'a pas dit aussi c'est qu'on
aurait pu il aurait pu faire un mea
culpa sur la politique d'équipement de
la France il est quand même incroyable
que les armées françaises que
l'industrie militaire française ait été
infoutu de faire ses drones de faire
c'est quand même un moyen de guerre
assez un arme assez simple le drone
alors que la Turquie a fait des drones
très efficaces qu'ils ont utilisé contre
les Arméniens avec efficacité et succès
et qu'ils ont vendu aux
Ukrainiens et qui est qui ça a beaucoup
aidé les Ukrainiens dans leur guerre
contre les Russes que l'armée française
et que l'industrie de défenseur est pas
été capable de faire des drones
devraient nous interroger parce que
sinon on aurait certainement livré des
drones à l'Arménie nous n'abandonnons
pas les Arméniens et les Arméniens
premier Emmanuel Macron vous retrouvez
toute cette petite partie sur ce papier
ce qu'il faut retenir vous le trouvez en
haut de la page d'accueil du figaro.fr
et lorsqu'on descend et bien regardez
dernière question que je voulais aborder
avec vous c'était la dernière question
posée Emmanuel Macron Macron affirme que
la France est au côté des femmes
iraniennes on rappelle qu'il y a en ce
moment un mouvement en Iran pour des
femmes qui veulent retirer leur voix
soutient la France soutient oral
d'Emmanuel Macron que peut faire
vraiment la France pour aider les
Iraniennes alors
c'est plus que simplement un mouvement
les femmes c'est-à-dire qu'il y a une
jeune femme qui avait laissé un peu
tomber
l'origine voilà son son voile et qui a
été arrêté par la police c'est
incroyable et qui ensuite
t'amener dans un commissariat où elle
est morte bon
et donc là ça a provoqué une sorte
révolution de révolte
d'abord des femmes et puis de l'ensemble
des Iraniens
contre cette injustice terrible
alors évidemment que
obligé
les femmes à se voiler d'ailleurs on a
remarqué que Sandrine Rousseau était
vous savez quoi je vous ai vu venir
est-ce qu'on essaierait pas d'épargner
Sandrine Rousseau je vous parle
d'Emmanuel Macron oui on sait qu'il y a
un conflit en France un débat en France
sur la question
elle n'a pas été la première à soutenir
les Iraniennes qui veulent se
débarrasser du voile qui est évidemment
un instrument de suggestions des femmes
c'est les les jeunes femmes iraniennes
nous le montrent tous les jours mais
ce que dit Emmanuel Macron est juste
aussi ce n'est pas
à la France de mettre le droit français
partout dans le monde si vous voulez
mettre le droit français partout dans le
monde vous pouvez le faire ça s'appelle
ça la culture française
mais on a renoncé à partir des 1960 à le
faire à amener les idées françaises et
quand la générosité française etc les
Américains ont essayé de mettre la
démocratie à l'américaine en Irak
c'était une catastrophe absolue ils ont
introduit en fait la guerre civile bien
et donc c'est
osiranien de
choisir leur propre leaders et choisir
leur propre système mais donc on peut
faire céder
on peut les soutenir moralement on peut
donner l'asile à des femmes qui
combattraient selon les idées de la
Révolution française et de des droits de
l'homme à la française l'égalité entre
les hommes et les femmes est-ce que nous
avons à nous substituer et dire
les Chinois doivent vivre comme vivent
les Français les Iraniens doivent vivre
comme une Française les Sud-Africains
comme des Français la réponse selon moi
et non parce que ça amène la catastrophe
je pense que il ne faut pas
rayonner par en étant des donneurs de
leçons je pense qu'il faut dire la
France ne reconnaît pas les régimes la
France reconnaît les pays et donc c'est
tout à fait normal que Macron serre la
main du président iranien a ici ça veut
pas du tout dire qu'il
qu'il soutient
le régime ça veut dire qu'il reconnaît
un grand pays avec lequel évidemment la
France qui est aussi un grand pays du
présent ici c'était à l'Assemblée
générale de l'ONU
pour faire avancer
des accords très intéressants qui sont
les accords nucléaires avec l'Iran de
pour empêcher la prolifération
qui toujours pour le coup et ça c'est le
crédit que vous lui accordez tente et
bien le dialogue avec n'importe quel
pays du monde mais oui parce que il faut
parler aux États nous ne reconnaissons
pas les régimes est-ce que le général de
Gaulle quand il a reconnu la Chine
populaire en 1964 est-ce qu'il avait la
moindre amitié pour le régime communiste
chinois pour pour la révolution
culturelle en Chine pas du tout mais le
général de gaulisée il faut prendre les
réalités telles qu'elles sont la réalité
c'est que il y avait un grand il y a
toujours un très grand pays qui
s'appelle la Chine ce pays est
communiste c'est pas nos idées mais
évidemment qu'il faut avoir des
relations d'état à état la diplomatie
c'est pas fait pour aller voir et parler
avec ses amis ses amis comme le Danemark
comme la Belgique on les voit tous les
mois au conseil
avec eux on se parle voilà on se parle
tous les mois à Bruxelles il y a aucun
problème l'appli la diplomatie c'est
fait pour parler
à aux gens qui sont différents de nous
aux gens avec lesquels nous ne sommes
pas d'accord qui ont des valeurs
différentes pour que ces différents ça
c'est le rôle de la diplomatie pour que
assez différent ne se transforme pas en
guerre nous n'approuvons pas le système
le système russe le système présidentiel
russe on trouve que nous nous trouvons
ça pas du tout normal d'ailleurs que
Monsieur Navalny soit en prison par
exemple bien mais nous considérons qu'il
faut parler à la Russie en tant qu'ETA
que ce n'est pas à nous de dicter aux
Russes le système qui doivent adopter
eux-mêmes mais nous parlons à la Russie
pour éviter
que nos différences idéologiques que
nous différent de vision du monde que
ces différences il faut les gérer ces
différences il faut éviter que ces
différences n'entraînent la guerre
voilà ce qu'on pouvait dire Renault
Gerard Garonne Ukraine carburant Arménie
Iran plein de sujets vous pouvez tout
savoir sur ce qu'a dit manuel Macron ce
soir tiens d'ailleurs pas de question
mais c'est vrai que le temps était
compté sur l'Italie par exemple ou sur
le Royaume-Uni mais on écoutera
évidemment le président de la République
j'en suis certain je pense que la
formation je vais vous répondre je pense
que la France doit rayonner la France
doit rayonner par son exemple
qui domine l'autre c'est la situation
aujourd'hui sur le terrain après les
victoires ukrainiennes et donc
j'invite j'aspire j'espère que nous
allons avoir des rouvrir c'est
négociations qu'on a eu on a eu des
négociations au mois de mars entre des
Russes et les Ukrainiens c'était à
Istanbul et bien j'espère que c'est
négociations pour reprendre vite en tout
cas que nous allons d'abord avoir un
cessez le feu parce que la priorité est
que ce conflit général régional ne
deviennent pas un conflit général la
principale information peut être la
phrase qui va tourner ce soir sur les
réseaux sociaux demain matin dans vos
journaux dans le Figaro c'est sans doute
celle-ci regardez Macron prévoit le
retour à la normale dans le courant de
la semaine prochaine paradoxal c'était
une interview sur les questions
internationales c'est cette phrase que
retiendront les Français parce que oui
une partie du pays est paralysée à cause
des ruptures des pénuries de carburant
merci beaucoup
vous voulez oui des grèves évidemment
pour revenez quand vous voulez et puis
nous on se retrouve demain bonne journée
bonne soirée avant tout